[Music]
okay in out news now out I think this
happened in Canada actually you can
write you're not gonna say anything okay
Lance and Chris al CRA's el Chris Dale
CRA's el a team quit his job at Walmart
with a rant over the intercom oh I think
it happened in Canada oh really
we had target for like for like three
years to they came and then and then
they failed they fail targeting Hargitay
because they it was like the Target
brand but they never didn't get any of
the products what from the states like
they had to get their own so all the
low-cost stuff that you love at your
target never made it north of the border
what so yeah it wasn't it was a seller
there was notice like the similar things
but the suppliers were differences yeah
expensive more expensive so the purpose
of target meant there you go yeah it's
tough to compete with Walmart and also
just a smaller country its Marcaida yeah
walmart sells things for like four
[ __ ] pennies and dates
well joke would you happen to know
anything that we can get out one what's
the price list yeah like what's the most
expensive chocolate erasers shot back oh
okay change it up much is a bucket of
paint over there 587 but just a flat
white is that what you exchange it for
sexual favors are not
so yeah you're right this did happen in
Canada and Grande smelled the maple
syrup all over that where's that where's
Grande Prairie like Grand Prairie it's I
mean there's the e at the end I'm
pronouncing the e Grande offensive dude
something we haven't heard I saw the
headline but I haven't watched the video
oh yeah airing his grievances over the
intercom the part time even though he
worked 40 plus hours a week I've been a
loyal employee applause I want to know I
was gonna buy the products [ __ ] Walmart
can I get those seven razor blades
please now Walmart carries fairtex
products takes gloves bags everything
pads everything we're tiger-like legit
legit random [ __ ] Walmart carries it
dude you could I didn't see it in store
but you could art order online and
they'll still ship it to the store you
just pick it up for free that's insane
awesome this one from a very anti
Walmart to like very Pro I was so
surprised he carry fairtex that's just
legit that isn't that's like straight-up
they have little more tied kids [ __ ]
make that [ __ ] dude oh let's convert
that back but these guys are warriors
though and they die at 30 mm okay
again write it back down no do their
seminars that 30 people go watches
seminars in 30 to 40 yeah man they're
warriors dude the ones that the one
that's surviving I'm a warrior I got a
worried warrior warrior a warrior I know
but I'm trying to play our warrior
that's why I was like I'm a warrior like
more like I'm W AR like he's worried
like oh yeah dammit
Geo I wanna call you Julia for a second
deuce that's cute I would love to I
would love to know what like the
management was doing because he's he at
the same point on himself I would love
just like a shot of everyone just being
like who is he where is he
yeah I'm just running around trying to
find this guy yeah that's so sad though
that he he he feels like he puts his
best foot forward and tries to work hard
and it's not like it's not reciprocated
back to him like that better bett
appreciation he was there for over a
year and a half and he's like I don't
regret what I did I went into this
knowing what will happen so he already
secured a new job before doing that so
but he knew that that was the way that
he wanted to go interesting I want to
and did the new job still take him in
knowing that after the video came out I
want to take him in yeah if I if I was
an employer it's like I understand that
you were slided but the way you did that
was very poor very immature I mean he's
17 super immature I would never do that
a temperature 70 Lomenzo ha ha ha I
would not have done that I did something
stupid when I used to work at Target
my manager pissed me off and then I had
to fix the cart things yeah I had to put
the load the carts up so then there were
you know it's a busy day so people are
walking out in and out and then this guy
was [ __ ] standing in the middle just
looking off into space and I was like
excuse me he wasn't paying attention so
I got the cart and I slammed it and then
cuz I got pissed off by the manager
right so I started grabbing all the
carts no slamming it all inside and then
he was like whoa you gotta be careful
and I'm like I told you to [ __ ] move
and then I went inside and I started
like getting pissed cuz I was like [ __ ]
this company man these managers this
managers [ __ ] ass right
brings me in the room and then she's
like what's going huh and I'm like man
you were [ __ ] disrespectful to me and
then she was like pretending like 180
flip and I'm like damn dude this this
place is [ __ ] a bunch of dumbasses
I'm a dumbass for being here like I
needed [ __ ] level up in life so I
don't have to work with people like this
and that's when I take a news started
boom yo face I mean I think there's a
common thread with all of us in the arts
where it's it's like difficult to to
work for other people oh yeah yeah I
think um hate myself for the first time
when I liked working for someone was
when I had a good leader and a good
manager
he wasn't like you know it was weird cuz
he wasn't the smartest person in the
world but I wanted to support him
because of how hard he worked and how
honest he was and how much he cared
about everybody so it made me want to
think for him and fix his problems
whereas every time everywhere else most
managers I feel like they weren't meant
to lead or be in that position but they
did it to serve themselves to get a
higher pay not that they cared about
their group or to the company and I
think the biggest thing that pissed me
off is like when I enter any job or
company I see it as a team and I see it
as a way for everybody to do well
together make money together and
whatever right so when I see
incompetence inefficiency stupid
politics all these things I start
[ __ ] hating everybody because I have
no control over that and I'm like if I
had this company I'd run it totally
different so I think over the years
that's what made me want to open up my
own company cuz I'm like there's so much
stupidity dude like if only this was my
company I'd do it differently I will say
like there are the difference in what
I'm willing to invest in somebody who I
know believes in Me versus somebody who
I know is just like you know ambivalent
or even worse just like in it for
themselves it's so different like you
you're willing to like come to work and
grind and hustle oh yeah you know if all
it takes is just a leader who like who
you trust yeah for sure man I would do
overtime a dual kinda stuff so I was
like [ __ ] it man like ride or die cuz
this guy's
he's awesome like he'll watch all of our
bags like
you'll go out get lunch for us and like
out of his own pocket he would get like
food for all of us and we don't pay as
much so it's just like yeah this is the
kind of like I think when you feel human
around people instead of product that's
when I think people back you up yeah
after I had an appendectomy because they
were kind of like dangling my job in
front of me by saying like oh you need
time off because you got surgery well I
don't know if you're gonna get the hours
when you come back I don't know if
you're gonna have a job I'm like what
hey first of all what's the epithet to
me I've been dekhta me when you get your
appendix removed okay yeah you dummy
this is wizardry Isaac was nine months
old fine I know what it is no and then I
had an infinite home and I'm just like
wow a manager at Babies R Us did that to
you huh I used to work at this other
company doesn't even exist anymore is it
no nope yeah and that's why I'm saying
yeah cuz they've treated their employee
that [ __ ] I used to work at this other
warehouse and then like there was this
time when that whole immigration debate
thing was going on right so a lot of the
the employees were like yeah
I got to take time off tomorrow and like
I got I got to do this thing right and
if my manager was straight-up like if
you don't come back tomorrow like you
don't have a job straight up and in
their life what all right [ __ ] it and
they all just basically quit and in one
day they that guy had to rush to like
look for like day laborers to fill up
the roles and I'm all like why did you
say that dude like you could add these
guys were good workers like just let him
take the day off like an IQ oh there was
plenty of people that could have covered
too but he was just on his ego trip like
if you don't come here tomorrow then you
don't have a job and I'm like that's
[ __ ] up yeah I wish I had
a lot of power to somebody I would never
use it but that's pretty crazy huh I was
so funny that he would say that he goes
oh [ __ ] that moment - it's like [ __ ] you
don't come tomorrow you ain't got a job
cool we quit on a second
you super stressed trying to find people
to fill the roles and I'm just like you
stupid man that's a weird constant you
decide you know what [ __ ] is calling me
the brakes yeah what do you mean you
don't need the braids you do need the
brakes on the car dude yeah it's [ __ ]
stupid he probably thought that you
would say that in like junior Hall
coming to work tomorrow yeah it was
pretty dumb I think a lot of people to
like know how [ __ ] up certain
companies are or like how how it works
right but then they also want their cake
and eat it too because walmart has
really low prices
mm-hmm everyone talks so much [ __ ] what
it's like it's hard not to shop there I
know that deal dude dude they got
[ __ ] westinghouse TVs for 80 bucks
[Laughter]
insignia those bands like Samia RCA what
sounds like the way we talk when we're
steak resting we don't go west right now
man I decorated for the buck TVs we
decorate our Christmas tree thanks to
Walmart you know cheap and I got
Listerine in a toothbrush or something
like we bought this Target Christmas
tree and it comes with the lights on it
already that's our Christmas tree honey
it's a JK that has lights and Intel from
one morning Dan no no but he's talking
about target and I'm like no let's talk
about target right now our time up
Walmart don't say that I don't I don't
know I don't know just treat it more
similar nice always like buying clothes
at Target but then I got like the
Walmart right
that partnership has ended but I will
still stand by it the clothes are dope
oh really you're wearing blue for
Walmart yeah yeah wash it wants to see
what happens there's stuff anyway
[Music]
you
[Music]